welcome back the Federal Reserve has
tightened the credit Market in the past
year to fight inflation in response home
buyers have to deal with higher mortgage
rates this is making home buyers
question if it's even possible to find
the right home in the current market
our next guest knows a thing or two
about real estate and says the Outlook
is better than you may think Ava weeks
has more
though rates keep climbing many of us
still need to buy or sell a home in the
current market and it shows says Re Max
president and CEO Nick Bailey we are
well into the spring market and we are
seeing a surge in activity sales from
February to March have jumped just over
30 percent and so we're seeing that
typical excitement coming into the
spring Market Bailey also shares this
advice for any prospective buyers in the
Vegas Market I think the first thing
that buyers have to consider is make
sure they have a good lender and their
shopping interest rates and also looking
at alternate mortgage products the
30-year fixed has obviously been at the
Forefront the last couple of years
because it's been so low but there are
other options out there there are
alternative rate mortgages there are
first-time home buyer mortgages with
lower interest rates and we have a
saying that you should marry the house
and date the rate there could be an
opportunity to refinance down the road
get more info insights at remax.com
well thank you again to Re Max for
sponsoring this segment Las Vegas now
we'll be right back